Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to create these cartoon-style
DeepFakes, and find out how much better this
new AI is than previous techniques. I think you
will be very surprised when you see the results.
So, what is exactly happening here? Well, in goes
a photo of us, and we also provide a target style,
and bam. We become a cartoon, an anime
character, or a caricature of ourselves.
That sounds absolutely amazing, so let’s
have a look at all three of these one by one.
Now hold on to your papers, Fellow Scholars, and
let’s start with my favorite first. Caricatures.
These are meant to exaggerate the facial
features of the test subject and we can
also provide a style. Here, Mr Bean
has a funny face, and to my delight,
all of the caricatures also have a funny feel
to them. That is absolutely amazing. A+ work
right there, little AI. Most of these also pass
the identity test - that is, if we were to cover
the photo of the real person, and just look at the
AIs interpretation, in almost all cases, we could
tell exactly who it is. That is absolutely
incredible. Just think about how difficult
it is to retain the identity of the input photo
while transforming it according to this style.
Also, glasses work. A variety
of hairstyles work. Finally,
an AI that creates amazing caricatures.
This is incredible. Loving it.
Two, next up, cartoons. The results
are still high-quality images,
I like that. Glasses and
hairstyles are still supported.
The identity test is still kind of okay here,
Harry Potter is definitely recognizable, in come
cases, Mr Bean too. Traces of the stubble of Mr.
DiCaprio are visible on some of the results, but
they are gone from most of the rest, and hence,
it would be difficult to tell exactly who this is.
Three, if we are looking to become
some anime characters, we see an even
more powerful demonstration of this effect.
Sometimes it feels like our input photos are
only taken into consideration to get the exact
position of the face, and hence I feel like we
are seeing the same one character in different
poses. Now this will make a very interesting
case study. Why? Well, perhaps the reason for
this is that these example images contain too
few detailed facial features to be able to redo
a real person into an anime version. Remember,
caricatures were extremely recognizable and
passed the identity test easily. So here,
I feel that we ran not into the limitations
of this AI, but into the limitations of the
concept itself. Actually, we can find
out about that ourselves. How? Well,
let’s compare this to what previous techniques
were capable of and see if this one is better.
First, we can inspect these images ourselves.
These are three previous techniques, and this
is the new method. Hmm. This one is called
GNR…Are you thinking what I am thinking? Yes,
this paper is called GANs N’ Roses. Yes, that
just happened. I am not kidding. This did not
perform that well at all, but StarGAN2…this
is actually not so bad. In some cases,
the quality of these images seems higher
than the new technique…until we realize
that is it not doing exactly what we asked
for. Remember, this is the input photo,
and this is the target. The input photo is meant
to be reimagined in the style of the target, and,
oh yes, there we are. Sometimes, this just keeps
giving us images that are good, but good is not
good enough here. These would have to be close
to the target style, and often, they aren’t.
Hence, I am really happy to see the
comparisons against the unsupervised
image-to-image translation technique because it
is doing something very similar to this technique,
but the quality differences are quite
striking. The new one is so much better.
Let’s see the user study from the paper and see
if others agree too. What? Is that really true?
Goodness! That is one of the cleanest wins for
a followup paper I have seen in a while. Wow.
Just look at that! And the incredible thing
here is that all of these techniques were
published in research papers from the last 2 to
3 years. These are from not so long ago at all!
You see, the progress in AI research is
nothing short of incredible. These amazing
new papers are popping up every year, and in
some fields, almost every week. So, with that,
we can soon become any character
when playing in a virtual a world,
and we can also choose how much of our identity
we wish to reveal. What a time to be alive!
So what do you think? What kind of character would
you like to become? Let me
know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!